[Musique]
étranger
étranger [
Musique] [
Musique]
[Musique]
merci
étranger,
vous ne les voyez pas à moins qu'ils ne veuillent que vous les voyiez,
ils sont très insaisissables, certaines personnes
les appellent des cueilleurs d'arbres quelque part entre
six  et huit pieds de haut et couvert de
fourrure brune ou rougeâtre ou noirâtre il était
sur des cheveux brun foncé à noir il avait un
front saillant nommé tête conique ils sont très prudents ils connaissent les
bois beaucoup mieux que nous et ils
ne le font pas  veulent être vus
la créature a des empreintes qui
ressemblent à ça c'est généralement gros et volumineux mais
ils ne savent toujours pas quelle
était la créature qui avait les morceaux
[Musique]
c'est Indian Creek et c'est là que
ces gens étaient quand ils l'ont vu
ramasser de l'eau  dans sa main, il y avait
quelque chose dans ma cour qui était gros et
lourd et faisait trembler le sol Je ne
pense pas que c'était un ours et ça ne ressemblait certainement pas
à un cerf et aussi dans cette grande
ombre avec des bras et des jambes dans le  la tête
marche derrière nous en allant dans cette direction
il a dit que mon biologiste l'avait découvert avec la
tête tordue a couru vers ma femme
et mes enfants et a dit allons-y allons-y
et là, je n'aime pas vous savez quel est
votre problème maintenant déménagez à
l'étranger
[Applaudissements]
Creek est probablement la base la plus concrète
pour Bigfoot
[Music]
si vous cherchez bigfoot et si
vous voulez trouver des gens qui
ont des informations sur Bigfoot Blue
Creek est le centre de cette histoire qui
en raconte l'histoire nous  il y a beaucoup de
gens dans notre communauté qui ont vu entendre sentir sentir
trouvé ses tanières vous
savez que nous pouvons trouver beaucoup de bonnes histoires
sur Bigfoot ici dans notre ville et nous
avons beaucoup de croyants bien il y a
plusieurs locaux
une variété de légendes locales et il y a un
beaucoup de traditions locales qui remontent
assez longtemps dans la vallée de Hoopa,
puis au nord dans la région d'Uric, puis au
nord-est dans la région de l'escroc,
je pense que les rumeurs, je veux dire, les histoires dans
la région remontent à
7 000 ans avec tous  les tribus locales
ont des histoires à ce sujet, il y a beaucoup
d'histoires amérindiennes de beaucoup de
créatures différentes dans les bois
et une créature de type Bigfoot fait partie de
celles-ci. Il y avait une histoire notoire
d'une créature Harrier plus grande
qui vivait dans cette région.
les cultures n'avaient pas d'image
d'un singe dans les premiers jours
[Musique]
les membres les plus traditionnels de la
culture vous diront probablement que c'est
un esprit d'une sorte que vous ne connaissez pas du tout d'
animal dans leurs langues ils
avaient tous des noms  qui reflétaient
des êtres physiques,
par exemple les White River Apache ont
un nom pour cette chose qui
signifie littéralement un grand homme poilu, les pieds noirs
du Montana ont un nom qui
signifie de grands pieds et ils ont tous une
compréhension différente de ce que
sont les Danae Navajo aux quatre
coins  euh
je crois que plus cet
être est vu souvent plus
nous sommes proches de la fin des temps
eh bien les gens les voient ici encore
à ce jour ce
sont des gens ordinaires
mais certaines de ces personnes travaillant dans
la région ont vu la créature la nuit vous
savez quand  ils rentrent du travail en voiture
juste en traversant les chemins de terre dans les
bois
les habitants qui pêchent ou chassent ils les voient
dans les montagnes
certains habitants décrivent les avoir vus
juste dans leur arrière-cour vous savez que nous
n'avons pas de clôtures ici nous avons votre
l'arrière-cour est des montagnes qui s'étendent sur
des kilomètres et des kilomètres et des kilomètres
en 1958, ils construisaient cette route là-haut
dans Bluff Creek, c'était un
bois vierge pour la plupart là-bas et
ils voulaient faire de l'exploitation forestière, il y avait
un projet de construction dans le  zone puis
ils ont trouvé des empreintes vraiment étranges et
cela est finalement sorti sur la côte
comme une histoire sur Bigfoot ces
morceaux originaux Ils avaient une apparence très humaine
vous savez et c'est là que
le mot le nom Bigfoot est vraiment
né
ils étaient  trouvé de nombreuses
fois autour des tracteurs, vous savez qu'ils
laissent les tracteurs là-haut la nuit et
rentrent chez eux ici pour la plupart et
euh quand ils reviendraient le matin,
ils trouveraient que c'est
[Music]
merci
Willow Creek  est
[Musique]
[Musique] il
y a ces primates mystérieux à peu
près partout dans le monde à travers l'
Europe centrale, l'Asie, la Sibérie, l'
Himalaya, le long de la côte de l'Asie,
tout au long du sous-continent indien jusqu'en
Afrique, vous connaissez l'Amérique du Sud
à propos du seul endroit où ils '  Ce n'est pas vraiment
décrit légitimement sur les
îles de Polynésie mais je veux dire
plus loin comme Hawaï mais dans toute
l'Indonésie il y a beaucoup de euh
ces singes mystérieux
Je suis convaincu qu'il y a Bigfoot et
ce n'est pas seulement ici c'est absolument
mondial
[Musique]
quand nous  eu je pense que c'était en
2003 Symposium Euh un scientifique russe est venu
de Russie et a apporté des livres sur
leur honnêteté qui est aussi une
créature Bigfoot et j'ai rencontré Heath qui était l'
éditeur d'un livre intitulé The yaoi en
Australie, donc ils ont une créature en
Australie qui est similaire  au Bigfoot
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
eh bien tu sais là je ne pense pas qu'il y
ait un chaînon manquant
euh nous je pense que nous sommes toujours des singes nous sommes des
primates nous sommes nous sommes très très étroitement
liés au chimpanzé
euh certains biologistes nous considèrent comme le
troisième chimpanzé vous savez
nous pensons que nous sommes très spéciaux vous savez et
différents et uniques parce que notre
civilisation a dominé le monde mais
euh nous sommes des animaux et nous avons évolué
naturellement
est
je regardais en bas de la pente pour  essayez de
voir si je pouvais voir ce que cela pourrait être si
vous savez que nous sommes parallèles
à l'esprit, la pente de la montagne est
comme ça Je suis ici ma famille est à environ
50 60 pieds ici sur le sentier
donc je suis  J'ai l'air génial, je vois un
mouvement du coin gauche de mon
œil
et je me tourne et je regarde vers le bas, c'est
quand j'ai vu Bigfoot quitter les pages du
mythe et de la légende pour devenir réalité
[Musique]
J'étais en haut de la montagne  pente
derrière un store naturel,
il ne pouvait pas me voir quand j'ai vu que
tout ce que je savais sur le plein air
a grandi dans l'Oregon a vécu en Alaska pendant 20
ans tout ce que je savais faire de la randonnée camping
pêcher un peu de chasse Came
Crashing Down
J'ai littéralement senti mon cerveau  redémarrage en cas de crash,
puis j'ai eu de véritables instincts de protection,
vous savez que c'était ma famille là-bas, j'ai
couru à travers les broussailles et les arbres
ont évité le contact visuel parce que la seule
chose que je savais quoi faire était en Alaska
avec le grizzly  Je ne fais pas le
contact visuel parce qu'ils le verront
comme un défi, alors j'ai évité le contact visuel, j'ai
couru vers ma femme et mes enfants et j'ai dit
allons-y, allons bouger et ils sont comme si
vous savez quel est votre problème, je vais  maintenant
bougez et ils sont comme d'accord alors
je les déplace sur le sentier de quelques
centaines de mètres autour d'un Switchback
encore cent mètres
Je ne vois rien Je
n'entends rien Je ne sens rien J'ai
dit les enfants
sur un  bûche et je leur donne de l'eau,
j'écarte ma femme et j'ai dit que vous n'allez pas
croire ce que j'ai vu et elle a dit
quoi et j'ai dit que j'ai vu Bigfoot et elle a
dit que je crois que ta
douceur
est
[la musique]
partout dans cet endroit  nous avons des observations de
routine je les ai vus utiliser
des imageurs thermiques je les ai vus utiliser la
vision nocturne j'ai été avec des gens qui les ont
vus que j'étais parce que je suis généralement
celui qui prend des photos et ainsi de
suite j'ai eu la chance de  les voir, je les ai fait
photographier en train de me regarder
photographier des empreintes de pas
des choses comme ça mais je suppose que nous
faisions toujours partie de l'équipe et j'avais mes devoirs et
tout le monde avait le leur
cette plage
de l'
autre côté de l'autoroute 96 s'appelle China
point pour China flat  et il s'avère
que
maintenant que je suis ici et que j'ai pu parler
aux gens ici, il y a probablement eu
15 ou 20 observations à ce stade si vous vous
arrêtez ici une seconde et écoutez
tout ce que vous pouvez entendre, c'est la rivière
que vous n'avez pas '  tu n'entends pas les voitures tu n'entends pas
les trains tu n'entends pas les bus tu
entends juste la rivière
donc euh
c'est un endroit unique
entre elle et ce garde-
corps est l'endroit où il s'est passé
quoi que ce soit qui soit
venu
de là-bas près de la rivière a
marché juste au-dessus de cela
a fait deux pas deux ou trois pas à travers
cette colline
et en seulement 30 secondes c'était
au sommet de ça
je '  Je vais mettre le sommet de cette crête énervée,
vous voyez que tous les arbres plus courts
n'étaient pas là
et cette personne a dit qu'elle avait entendu
la lutte là-haut, c'était un cerf qui
a regardé là-haut et cette chose
regardait debout là au bord en
la regardant  et quand il s'est retourné
pour s'éloigner,
elle pouvait voir la plante de ses pieds et
ils étaient de couleur plus claire
cette expérience et le voir pour la
première fois moi-même
est la raison pour laquelle j'ai commencé à enquêter sur
Bigfoot parce qu'avant cela, je pensais que c'était
une nouveauté et une sorte d'intéressant
mais quand j'ai vu les preuves matérielles
qui étayaient les rapports des témoins oculaires
ici,
je savais qu'il devait y avoir quelque chose de plus,
alors je suis allé sur la route pour découvrir
[Music]
étranger [
Music]
[Music] étranger
dans la salle Bigfoot est principalement
casté  de personnes qui ont pris des
pistes comme Al Hudson dont le conservateur ici est un
ami de longue date de John Green qui a
l'un des premiers écrivains sur
Bigfoot et d'autres personnes de la région
qui, au fil des ans, ont
vu des moulages où ils ont repris le casting
et  apporté et il y a aussi quelques-uns
des premiers articles écrits dans les
journaux sur le fait d'avoir vu des pistes ce
qu'elles étaient et ce genre de choses et
ça vient de grandir à partir de là
Al Hodgson
euh qui m'a donné ce casting il a signé le
dos ici il est toujours en vie  ici
juste en haut de la colline,
ils ont trouvé ces traces et ils
connaissaient un type nommé Bob
titmus qui était taxidermiste à Anderson
en lisant ici sur l'autoroute cinq euh
et il avait appris à l'équipage de Jerry comment faire des
moulages en plâtre donc l'équipage de Jerry  est vu sur une
photo dans l'humble journal Times
tenant la piste comme celle-ci, vous savez et
cela a vraiment fait une grande impression sur
à peu près tout le monde, donc il a frappé le
fil de presse AP et il a été diffusé dans le
monde entier
merci
ce qu'il est important de  dire, c'est que
les gens supposent simplement que vous pouvez faire un
contreplaqué découpé dans un Bigfoot
et faire un tas
d'empreintes de pas qui vont tromper
quelqu'un
[Musique]
si vous avez des pieds plus grands
que vos pieds réels alors  c'est comme
les raquettes, pourquoi les gens auraient-ils
des raquettes pour qu'elles ne s'enfoncent pas bien dans
la neige
de la même manière si vous allez
être une personne à taille humaine avec de très
gros pieds, vous n'allez
même pas vous enfoncer  à de la boue assez molle, donc si vous avez
comme ça un certain nombre de choses ne
vont pas changer votre poids ne va pas
changer votre longueur de foulée ne va pas
changer en fait si quelque chose va
devenir plus court parce que vous  Vous êtes si maladroit
de porter ces choses agglomérantes,
mais tout aussi important, vous êtes la façon dont un
pied en contreplaqué touche le sol n'est pas la
façon dont leur vrai pied touche le sol, les vrais
pieds
ont des changements de position de remorquage lorsque les vrais pieds
touchent le sol si c'est un pied
au fur et à mesure qu'ils avancent et qu'ils font une
pause juste là au niveau des orteils, il y a un
peu de crête de terre repoussée
il y a toutes sortes de choses dynamiques qui
se produisent avec un vrai pied mais pas avec
un truc en contreplaqué Professeur des
universités physiques
[Musique]
[  Musique]
Patterson et gimlin
se filment sur The Sandbar, vous savez,
alors ils ont changé que lorsqu'ils sont arrivés
à Bigfoot sur le film, la pellicule s'est
en fait terminée et c'est à ce moment-là que vous voyez
la créature s'éloigner au
loin, ça se termine Malheureusement, ils
ne pouvaient pas  suivez-le et obtenez plus de séquences
qu'ils devaient continuer, il est allé sous une
bâche, vous savez, et a changé la pellicule
avec un nouveau rouleau de film,
vous savez, beaucoup de gens veulent faire de
Bigfoot une sorte de grand
monstrueux fascinant et glorieux  Légende,
vous savez, mais euh,
si la vérité n'est qu'une chose banale et ordinaire,
euh, c'est plus précieux pour moi qu'un
grand conte
pour que vous marchiez en amont ici, vous devriez
parcourir environ 25 à 30 miles pour entrer au
cœur du Bluff Creek  Bassin versant et
la zone où le film a été tourné, les
célèbres découvertes d'empreintes euh et tout
[Musique]
les gens en parlent partout où vous allez
et l'histoire de celui-ci est juste
partout dans le paysage ici si vous
l'étudiez du tout, vous savez
euh
je peux  Je ne peux pas m'en empêcher parce que les gens me disent que
vous savez qu'à Aiken's Creek, ils ont
trouvé une empreinte il y a quelques années
et que les gens viennent avec leurs
photographies d'empreintes de pas et d'ombres
dans les bois qu'ils pensent être Bigfoot
vidéo Captain Bluff Creek
c'est
[  Musique]
merci
[Musique]
le film ce soir eh
bien c'est le euh c'est une image la
plus célèbre du
film Patterson gimlin de 1967 à Bluff Creek
étranger
et cela a été tiré d'un scan de 50 mégaoctets
à partir d'un transparent qui a été pris
du film original
[Musique]
la plupart des gens qui ont vu le film et
le rejettent comme flou et granuleux
euh
ne réalisent pas qu'il y a ce genre de
qualité d'imagerie
euh si vous pouvez voir ça euh
euh si nous pouvions juste trouver cet original
filmer ou obtenir une version publiée de cela,
je pense que cela convaincrait
beaucoup plus de gens que
vous ne voyez pas comme les fermetures éclair et les coutures et les
rabats amples et et la fausse fourrure vous voyez
quelque chose qui ressemble à des muscles qui
bougent sous la peau
euh toi  voir euh ce qui semble être le
mouvement des mains et des orteils et du
visage et des seins sur le devant de la
créature
[Musique]
le film étranger
ça a l'air sacrément réaliste euh c'est
euh c'est quand même pas suffisant pour
prouver que la créature est  réel et pour
chaque personne qui croit que c'est un
vrai Bigfoot, il y en aura un autre qui
dira que cela ressemble à un homme
en costume de singe.
un regard sur la photo de Patterson
qui est sur notre mur lorsque vous entrez par
la porte et l'un a dit à l'autre
oh vous pouvez voir la fermeture éclair du visage faite et
c'est un gars en costume bien si vous regardez
rapidement le film de Patterson  est une
femme Bigfoot ce n'est pas un gars en
costume
monsieur
[Musique]
même Hollywood a dit à l'époque que
Patterson a filmé en 67 ce costume
n'aurait pas pu être fabriqué
bien vous savez je pense que la preuve serait de
trouver un corps d'un euh j'espère  vous
savez pas traqué et tué mais
quelque chose trouvé le long de l'autoroute un
morceau de corps
euh il y a ces tentatives maintenant avec la
génétique pour le prouver par l'ADN maintenant
certaines personnes disent que des preuves ADN
suffiraient mais vraiment il n'y a eu aucune
preuve ADN de cela le  les gens ont
soumis euh des fibres capillaires et toutes sortes
de choses différentes il y a eu récemment une
étude
publiée en ligne par un vétérinaire et
nommé Ketchum qui a dit que vous savez que nous avons
cette preuve ADN et tout ce qu'elle a réellement
découvert, c'est qu'il y avait du
matériel génétique des gens et puis  il y avait
des anomalies mais les anomalies ne
prouvent pas qu'il y a Bigfoot cela signifie simplement qu'elle a
trouvé des anomalies vous pouvez trouver des
anomalies dans toutes sortes de
matériel génétique étranger
J'ai passé environ 10 ans à être un
chercheur agressif avec tout
l'équipement de haute technologie
et n'ayant jamais eu de visuels ou
d'interactions, il y avait un groupe de
personnes dans le monde du Bigfoot
qui suggéraient une accoutumance,
vous savez, sortez et faites le truc du Dr Jane
Goodall avec les
chimpanzés, j'ai bien fait ça dans ce nouveau
domaine,
il  leur a pris cinq ans
avant qu'ils ne prennent de la nourriture dans mes bols de cadeaux
la technique du Dr Johnson
hier matin, je savais que j'allais partir
pour venir ici et filmer et je devais
emballer le camp
et donc je me suis éloigné d'où
le camp de base  à l'endroit où se trouve la zone de literie principale
et je me tenais sur la zone plate au-dessus de l'endroit où
la zone de literie principale de Betty va sur les
pentes, c'est sur la pente du flanc de la
montagne et je me tenais à environ 70 pieds
en arrière de la crête de l'endroit où elle
descend et je me tenais là  pendant une bonne demi-
heure
et j'ai chanté quelques chansons, j'ai sifflé quelques
airs et je suis resté là,
puis j'ai entendu craquer craquer
Crunch et papa ont remonté la colline,
sont venus au-dessus de la crête, il s'est tenu là,
il m'a regardé
puis il a baissé les yeux vers  mon petit chien par
terre
puis il m'a regardé
puis il s'est retourné
et a redescendu la montagne
[Musique]
oh [
Musique]
Jésus
le Bigfoot sur la qualité
[Musique]
tout le monde aime
un bon mythe
et surtout
les mythes qui sont  les meilleurs mythes et la
meilleure
euh science-fiction
sont toujours ces histoires qui ne sont qu'à un
demi-pas de la réalité celles
qui sont vraiment scandaleuses celles qui sont
vraiment difficiles à croire vraiment que vous
ne pouvez pas enfoncer votre pensée derrière
cela parce que c'est trop
les gens scandaleux euh aiment les histoires
et ils aiment croire en ces
histoires, donc je suis juste un peu intéressé
par tout le phénomène, principalement pourquoi
les gens croient ce qu'ils font et en
particulier celui-ci, il me semble si
incroyable que Carl Sagan a dit
extraordinaire  les affirmations nécessitent des
preuves extraordinaires
et il n'y a aucune preuve, mais il y a
beaucoup d'affirmations extraordinaires, vous savez
que la nature de la perception humaine est si
fluide que vous devez remettre en question
tout ce que les gens disent avec vous savez que
vous ne pouvez même pas obtenir une
réponse directe à propos d'un  un crime ou un accident de voiture,
vous savez, certaines personnes diront que le gars
avait une chemise rouge, d'autres disent que vous aviez une
chemise verte et que la mémoire n'est pas
fiable tout le temps,
mais je pense que vous pouvez
toujours construire une créature possible à partir
de  ces observations, vous devez faire
attention à ne pas simplement créer votre propre
mythe, vous savez que vous créez votre propre
nouvelle légende, vous voulez être un
enquêteur honnête et, espérons-le, pas un
créateur de Miss dilué
et de la science-fiction qui n'est qu'un
demi-pas  de la réalité, c'est comme si
je pouvais en quelque sorte entrer dans le vif du sujet et
parce que oui, à un moment donné, il y avait de nombreuses
espèces d'humains qui couraient partout et
certains d'entre eux étaient gros et poilus et
se tenaient vraiment grands gigantopsicus qui ont
été trouvés en Afrique, vous savez ce que
les gens pensent vraisemblablement  ces choses
correspondent au moule d'accord, donc c'est comme si d'accord,
cette créature existait dans le passé
sur la planète, alors peut-être qu'elle pourrait encore
être ici et donc
il y a beaucoup de forêt ici qui n'a pas
été touchée
et donc il y a cette idée que bien si
c'est soi-disant inexploré
que cela pourrait être là où se trouve Bigfoot, mais la
zone n'est pas vide d'humains il y a
des milliers et des milliers et des milliers de
kilomètres de routes de vlogging la forêt ici
fournit une source continue de bois
il y a beaucoup de gens pour gagner leur vie
en travaillant  ces montagnes travaillent dans
ces forêts et elles sont partout
et les routes vont
partout et il y a des gens là-bas
tout le temps et qui sont étrangers depuis
très longtemps
Je sais qu'il y a une tendance naturelle que
les humains ont à  voir ce genre de formes
dans les bois, vous connaissez Boogeyman ou
toutes les formes fantomatiques étranges que nous avons tendance
à nous voir dans les bois,
surtout dans le noir quand nous avons peur
la nuit, vous savez euh c'est une
chose courante qui remonte à l'enfance et
le monstre sous votre lit ou quoi que ce soit
bien Bigfoot est une histoire amusante c'est
mystérieux et quand vous êtes dans les
bois et qu'il fait noir et que les étoiles sont
éteintes et que vous êtes avec vos amis autour
du feu de camp et que vous commencez à raconter
des histoires que vous pensez  wow comme ce serait incroyable qu'il y
ait cette créature
ici autour de nous
et
les gens aiment que vous sachiez qu'ils aiment les
histoires légendaires quiconque travaille dans
les bois vous dira toujours qu'il y
a des moments où vous savez que
les cheveux sur le dos  de votre cou se
lèvera euh que vous pensez que vous voyez
quelque chose du coin de l'œil
et nous sommes nous-mêmes des animaux autant que
les gens ne veulent pas l'admettre
et donc
euh nous avons des compétences de survie qui sont profondément ancrées
dans notre psychisme  cela nous a aidés à survivre à
toutes ces centaines de milliers
d'années
et donc
quand vous vous déplacez dans les bois bien
sûr parfois vous êtes comme quoi
j'ai entendu quelque chose
surtout si vous n'êtes pas habitué à travailler
ou à vivre dans cet environnement  et
vous visitez
euh vous êtes déjà déséquilibré vous ne
voyez déjà pas les choses que
vous avez normalement l'habitude de voir
et donc vous ne savez pas quels sont les déclencheurs
pour vous protéger
et donc votre imagination sera vraiment
accrue  pour vous garder en sécurité et donc chaque
petit indice qui se produit là-bas une
brindille qui claque une branche d'arbre que vous savez
se déplaçant dans le vent euh
et puis bien sûr les grands animaux
que nous avons qui vivent ici les
ours euh le wapiti le cerf
euh ils font  semble que tout cela
contribuera au fait que j'ai peut-être
vu quelque chose et que votre esprit va aux
courses que vous connaissez et surtout avec
ce mythe omniprésent de ce gros
animal poilu que vous savez piétiner
là-bas, vous êtes bien peut-être que c'était Bigfoot
mes collègues et moi avons dit oh ouais
c'était un jour Bigfoot ouais
ouais certainement vous savez que quelque chose est
sorti des
catégories de Chief Benson
[Musique] il y a
eu un certain nombre de personnes qui
ont créé des canulars qui ont fourni de
soi-disant preuves pour le bigfoot  vous savez
les
pas dans la boue et euh et les
observations et le et et le film du
gars en costume de singe se promenant
[Musique]
Wilbur Wallace les superviseurs
sa forme de morceaux qu'il avait fait
avec ces empreintes en bois Stompers
ont commencé à faire pipi ici et ils ont une
apparence très différente, vous savez qu'ils
sont plus en forme de sablier et ils
ont une apparence étrange euh maladroite, ceux-ci ont
commencé à apparaître partout
et et beaucoup de ces
ouvriers du bâtiment et forestiers locaux qu'ils
aiment jouer  des blagues sur les Outsiders, vous connaissez
quelqu'un dans le monde,
c'était très drôle, je pense qu'ils devaient
les faire venir du
Canada euh et regarder de fausses empreintes
[Musique]
Je pense que l'un des aspects du
Bigfoot  l'histoire est combien de canulars il y a eu
et avec quelle facilité il est d'amener les
croyants liquides à croire aux
canulars parce que certaines des pistes que
vous trouvez ont juste l'air ridicules euh
ridicules et beaucoup d'entre elles proviennent
probablement d'ours ou vous savez qu'elles sont
juste des formes étranges dans le sol, les gens
ont dit qu'ils avaient trouvé Prince et il a
été démontré qu'il y a des empreintes d'ours,
ils sont capables de le retracer jusqu'à un autre
test animal l'ADN découvre qu'il
appartient à un animal différent dont
nous savons qu'il existe
je  signifie que vous en trouvez d'autres que je veux dire
que pouvez-vous en faire comme ça
[Musique]
c'est prétendu être une piste juvénile de Bigfoot
euh beaucoup de gens pensent que Bigfoot
est si énorme et que euh
quand ils voient des empreintes humaines dans le
la boue, ils pensent bien que cela pourrait être une
piste Bigfoot et alors vous arrivez au
point où vous savez comment faire la
différence, tout ce
que les humains font pourrait être prétendu être
Bigfoot, vous savez que
c'est très problématique, surtout quand
les gens veulent vraiment  mal de voir Bigfoot
ou de prouver Bigfoot,
je pense que cela prête à plier les
preuves et à
interpréter les choses en faveur de son
expérience d'hypothèse préférée à l'étranger,
ce sont probablement de très gros
animaux, donc ils mesurent peut-être six sept huit
pieds si vous avez compris le  poids
peut-être cinq cents livres très
gros animal,
ils devraient laisser un impact très important
sur l'environnement que nous pouvons détecter
où ils se nourrissent où ils se
couchent si vous savez où qu'ils
traversent leur vie quotidienne,
vous savez que ces choses sont  super duper à
longue durée de vie et ils ne s'accouplent que tous les 100
ans
ou il est vraiment peu probable qu'ils puissent
survivre ou nous voyons le tout dernier d'entre
eux et ils sont sur le point de disparaître
et puis dans ma propre profession il y a un certain
nombre d'espèces en voie de disparition  qui vivent
dans cette région et surtout avec l'
avènement des nouvelles technologies, nous
détectons assez facilement des animaux de plus en plus rares,
même de petits carnivores qui ne
mesurent qu'un pied ou deux de long ne pèsent que
quelques livres et il y a moins de 100 de
ces choses et nous  sommes capables de
les détecter parce que nous utilisons des pièges photo et
des engins de détection qui nous permettent de trouver ces
animaux extrêmement rares
dans aucune de ces enquêtes dont il y
a eu des centaines dans cette région avons-
nous déjà repéré
l'observation de Bigfoot dans l'un de nos  les études
jamais jamais et donc c'est comme si je pouvais si
je pouvais trouver un animal dont il n'y en a que
moins d'une centaine ils ne font que
quelques pieds de long et ils existent dans cette
zone de milliers de kilomètres carrés si je
peux les trouver
pourquoi je peux '  t Je trouve qu'un primate de huit pieds de haut et 700
livres
[Musique]
est
plus j'y regarde, plus
je deviens convaincu ou du moins plus
je suis convaincu que toutes les théories
du canular
sont fausses et vous avez  pour le regarder,
je pense que dans une image plus large, presque
tout le monde dans chaque État de l'Union
a eu un épisode d'un type ou d'
un autre de Bigfoot
étranger
qui prétend être l'homme en
costume de Bigfoot ne sait même pas comment décrire
comment  arriver à ce site de film qui est
vous savez comme je l'ai dit à environ 60 miles
dans les Backwoods sur des chemins de terre accidentés
et il sa description de la région
ressemble plus à six miles de l'
autoroute euh ce n'est pas ce n'est pas convaincant
il n'y avait aucun moyen que  vous pouvez
absolument entrer là-dedans, sauf comme
Patterson et Gimlin qui ont abordé
les problèmes de Horseback
[Musique]
en science, ce sera vraiment difficile de
contester un seul
point de données, vous ne pouvez pas
tout ce que vous pouvez faire, c'est aller bien, vous avez fait
une observation  super allons voir si nous
pouvons le faire encore et encore et encore et
encore et obtenir une base solide de
preuves pour prouver l'existence euh du
sable le problème ultime avec le
clip du film est encore comme je l'ai dit nous
n'en avons pas eu d'autre  des images décennie
après décennie de milliers et de milliers
de personnes qui courent partout pour
essayer de trouver plus de preuves de Bigfoot
Liberty
[Musique]
Bigfoot représente en quelque sorte la fin de
la civilisation aussi, vous savez ce qui
existe en dehors d'elle et malgré cela et ne
peut jamais  être trouvé par là, donc
c'est un peu approprié pour la
légende du Bigfoot ici aussi
[Musique] des
groupes de personnes qui remontent dans les
bois là-bas à la recherche d'un Bigfoot
pour la plupart des gens totalement ordinaires, vous
ne les connaîtriez pas depuis Adam ou Eve ou
n'importe qui
Joe's six-pack ou quoi que vous sachiez,
ils sont généralement mariés avec des enfants et
des emplois et la plupart de ces gens qui
viennent ici lors de ces expéditions, c'est
comme leur grande aventure, c'est
des vacances et ils veulent vivre
quelque chose de différent
étranger
de gens que je dirais viennent et veulent
aller à Bluff Creek où Patterson a filmé,
donc à partir du début du mois de mai, lorsque le
soleil brille tout au long de l'été,
c'est une procession régulière jusqu'à
Bluff Creek et jusqu'au champ de Patterson
ou là où ils pensent Patterson  filmé, vous
savez, au fil des années, des gens ont
appelé et ont dit que nous venions de l'Ohio
et de quelle taille de fusil ai-je besoin
pour tirer sur cette chose, quelle est sa taille et
nous avons donc eu tous les spectres que j'ai eu  les gens
visitent j'ai fait venir un jeune homme et sa femme pour
leur anniversaire de
Pennsylvanie où ils avaient économisé l'
argent pour venir il avait un tatouage Bigfoot
qui allait de son genou au haut de
sa hanche et il avait pensé à Bigfoot
toute sa vie depuis  sa jeunesse et avait
hâte d'arriver ici et d'aller à
Bluff Creek et d'explorer cette région et de
chercher Bigfoot
étrangère
[Musique] [
Musique]
le plus grand festival ou défilé centré
autour de Bigfoot serait celui de
Willow Creek c'est Bigfoot  jours, cela s'est
produit il y a quelques semaines pour cette année
et nous avons des gens qui déguisent ce
Bigfoot et vous avez, je veux dire, la moitié de la
ville est habillée en Bigfoot
[Music]
certains des défilés auront une douzaine de
Bigfoot marchant dans le défilé
représentant les casinos et représentant
des entreprises représentant des groupes, donc Bigfoot
a été tout un phénomène dans cette
communauté. J'ai
été deux fois le défilé du Grand Marshal of Bigfoot
Days, donc je suis certainement un parti
pour profiter de Bigfoot
Bigfoot est une mascotte de Willow Creek si
vous allez en ville, vous allez  voir au moins
trois ou quatre grandes statues en bois sculptées
de Bigfoot il y a quelques
entreprises nommées d'après Bigfoot il y a du
rafting Bigfoot il y a des livres Bigfoot
évidemment il y en
a
quatre il y a quatre ou cinq grandes peintures murales
en ville
[Musique]
Je pense que c'est vraiment amusant de penser qu'il
y a  une grande chose poilue ressemblant à un humain qui
court là-bas
euh je veux dire quelle histoire merveilleuse c'est
euh et
qui je sais rend les gens heureux ça
leur donne de la joie qu'il y ait ce mystère là-bas qui
erre là-bas ça donne aux
gens de l'espoir ça leur donne du bonheur  C'est
un merveilleux sens du mystère
euh que vous savez que nous n'avons pas conquis
chaque centimètre carré de la planète,
ils sont toujours vraiment sauvages,
des choses vraiment étranges là-bas,
tout cela aide à bien propulser le mythe
parce que j'ai été dans ces bois
[Musique]
pendant une bonne partie de ma vie et je chasse
et je pêche et je voyage et je vois
tous les animaux qui sont dans ces
bois
si s'il y avait un Bigfoot, ce
serait l'endroit où il serait certainement
pourrait exister et vivre une
vie plutôt insouciante sans être inhibé par l'
homme parce que c'est un pays immense
et c'est un pays accidenté et escarpé et pour
quelqu'un qui veut se cacher c'est
l'endroit pour le faire
étranger
[Musique]
merci